let's not your heart be troubled  ye believe in God believe also in me  in my father's house are many mansions  if it were not so I would have told you  I go to prepare a place for you  and if I go and prepare a place for you  I will come again and receive you unto  myself  that where I am their ye may be also  and whether I go you know and the way  you know  Thomas saith unto him  Lord  we know not whether thou goest and how  can we know the way  Jesus saith unto him  I am the way the truth and the life  no man cometh unto the father  but by me  if ye had known me you should have known  my father also  I'm from henceforth ye know him and have  seen him  Philip saith unto him  Lord  show us the father and it suffices us  Jesus saith unto him  have I been so long time with you and  yet hast thou not known me Philip  he that hath seen me hath seen the  father  thanks be to God